question web à présent du jour la marche
pour l'égalité contre le racisme à 40
ans vous souvenez-vous de cet événement
et vous êtes une majorité un 66 % à
répondre non en revanche à Joué les
Tours on s'en souvient de cet événement
et oui la ville a célébré ce weekend les
40 ans de la marche pour l'égalité et
contre le racisme souvenez-vous on est
le 3 décembre 1983 un car quitte le
quartier de la Rabière à jouer les tours
pour rejoindre le cortège national
aujourd'hui certains participants de
cette marche souhaitent rappeler ranimer
leur combat qu'il jugent toujours
d'actualité Faustine luno c'était en
1983 et 40 ans plus tard on célèbre
encore cette marche d'un mois et demi
entre Marseille et Paris ce weekend a
joué les tours une trentaine de
personnes ont marché contre le racisme
comme à l'époque je me souviens
surtout effectivement de la marche
j'étais quand même assez impressionné si
je me souviens la longueur du trajet
c'est plus de 1000 km à pied et euh de
l'importance que ça a pris 83 donc
l'année de la marche c'était l'année
record des meurtres raciste et que
depuis 40 ans cette affaire là bah voilà
on on n pas réussi à la régler tous les
jours malheureusement on voit encore
qu'il y a des actes racistes euh que les
gens souffrent il y a beaucoup de
souffrance 1200 m entre l'hôtel de ville
et le centre social de laarabière en
souvenir des 1200 km de la Marche des
beurs comme elle fut surnommé par les
médias de l'époque un remake à
l'initiative de plusieurs associations
de quartiers le but c'est de réveiller
un petit peu les consciences les mémoire
pour ceux qui étaient là mais surtout
lancer quelque chose auprès des jeunes
qui à mon sens se démobilis ou son
fatalisent par rapport à la question de
du racisme pour l'occasion deux
marcheuses de l'époque Malik bouédien et
Marie lormaille était présente pour
témoigner de cette entreprise qui a
marqué leur vie elle qui s'était jointe
au mouvement choquée par par plusieurs
meurtres xénophobes perpétrés dans les
années 80 c'était dur mais on savait que
c'était pour quelque chose de de
d'important en tout cas on avec on avait
20 ans à l'époque mais on savait qu'il
fallait le faire maintenant on a 60 ans
et plus et et on souhaite vraiment que
d'autres
sachent connaissent cette histoire et
sen enempart et et en fasse quelque
chose en fait en France 12600
infractions caractère raciste xénophobe
ou antireligieux ont été enregistrés par
les services de police et de gendarmerie
en